hey youtubers it's Charlie this is my
arrow episode 19 video so many WTF
things to talk about we do have a really
good idea where the rest of the season
is going based on what happened in this
episode based on what happened at the
end and adjust some information from the
producers on like what their plan is for
future seasons based on what happened so
just careful for spoilers as we get like
right into it I'll explain the big stuff
first so before top five moments let's
just talk about Colton Haynes and what's
going on with that the actor is coming
back to the show he's just done as a
series of regular series regulars
typically appear in every single episode
almost every single episode so when he
comes back he'll just be a guest star
we're supposed to see him again before
the end of this season and I think I'll
have something to do with what's going
on with Thea
he'll also guest star in season four the
spin-off show and on the flash as for
future seasons like nothing's been
officially locked down Colton Haynes
just said that he totally wants to come
back and guest star so he's open to it
as much as it's a huge surprise I
actually think the way they did it this
way is actually necessary I think it's a
good thing because now they have more
room to develop Thea as the Mia Dearden
speedy character I think it's pretty
clear that she's gonna take Roy's spot
on the team eventually once we get
through all this crazy racial gold stuff
when Colton first came on the show he
had a two year deal so they knew that he
had a hard out at a certain time so they
just they wrote it that way so it was
pre-planned the whole time they knew
this was gonna happen he has a big movie
career that's taking off he's in the san
andreas movie with the rock so he has
other big huge things going on in his
career right now so on a top five
moments starting with number five meet
death bolt if you guys don't remember
Doug Jones he played Abe Sapien
in the Hellboy movies he's also done a
lot of other creature work with
Guillermo del Toro he was a lot of fun
as a villain in this episode and I was
kind of glad that he wasn't using like a
weird voice I think that the voice he
used was effective he is a character
from the comics I think they changed it
just a little bit the way his powers
work just to play on the the Superman
jokes that they always try to use
whenever Brandon Roth is on screen I've
been pretty surprised at the number of
Superman jokes that they worked in this
season so far
like we're really just starting to get
to see Ray Palmer now like his character
is a much bigger deal now than it was
earlier this season so I think once we
get through the end of season 3 they'll
slowly back off of like the Superman
puns they're really two big reasons the
death bolt came on the show one to put
through his paces you know so he kind of
reaffirm his mission as a hero and to to
tease other metahumans that weren't in
Central City when the particle
accelerator exploded that second one is
a much bigger deal I think that'll
inform some stuff that's gonna be
happening in the spin-off show as well
as season two of the flash and arrow the
way Cisco explained it death bolt was
already a metahuman in another city when
the particle accelerator exploded and as
far as they know so far I mean up to up
to this episode up to this moment the
only metahumans were ones that were in
Central City affected by the blast
so either the blast affected people all
over the world or there is some other
thing that's creating metahumans some
other mechanism that's giving people
powers there's still a couple things
that the show is trying to set up that I
think it'll explore more in future
season so it's just like this is just
one more thing that it's teasing out on
to number four Roy versus the prison it
was in the promos we knew he was
probably gonna get stabbed we just
didn't know how it was gonna go down I
would say this fight scene probably
Colton Haynes best fight scene all
season he hasn't really gotten that many
good moments the second half of the
season so far
I think they planned it that way because
they knew that it was good it was gonna
go down like this so they wanted him to
go out on a really big note on number
three Quentin goes apeshit on Oliver he
ransacks the arrow cave ransacked Thea's
apartment and it's still going after
Oliver even after Roy is confirmed dead
I mean as far as he knows Roy's dead
they didn't make that very clear in that
last scene with them he thinks that Roy
is dead even though his superiors told
him to back off Oliver because they're
like well Roy is the arrow he confessed
why are you going after Oliver Queen
Quentin knows that Oliver is the arrow
so that's why he's still going after him
but he can't tell everyone that because
he can't explain Rachele goal he just
doesn't have the right kind of evidence
to go to his superiors with by all
accounts the arrow is dead that that's
actually a really big thing put a
bookmark on that that means a number of
things you know most notably Oliver will
not be using the arrow identity for the
rest of the season that's where that
League of Assassins costume comes in the
whole situation with Thea is probably
what's going to compel him into the
league he'll be like Rach Amell for the
rest of the season the other thing is
that he's going to have to become the
arrow again at some point and they'll
have to explain that to the city because
the city thinks that the arrow is dead
Quinton is still
in a harbour a grudge against Oliver
Hill price they'll go after him in his
free time even if he can't use police
resources to do it
on to number two Oliver and Ray Palmer
team up I was really hoping you played
more video games as a child that
probably one of the funniest lines in
the episode I was kind of wondering
where they were gonna take that neural
interface that they teased earlier in
the episode like a suit that can move
independent of your muscles Tony Stark
can remote pilot Iron Man armor so it
might be something similar to that in
the future like look forward to some
twists on what they can do with that
ability the suit itself the atom suit
doesn't have an AI so to speak I don't
think they're gonna do that I think that
would be too close to Iron Man I do feel
like they waited a little too long to
start doing character development that
they did with the atom in this episode
like he's like oh I can solve stuff with
my tech and Oliver is like no you can't
rely on your tech you have to rely on
your own abilities he's kind of going
through the same thing that laurels
going through as the The Black Canary
she's trying to become a hero but she's
not very good at it
ray wants to be hero too he's also not
very good at it what I think is gonna
happen with the character is it he'll
become a slightly better hero by the end
of the season and then they'll just
continue that character development in
the spin-off show they did say the
character fits way better with team
flash so what I'm hoping is is that he
guest stars more on the flash season two
than he does on arrow season four I just
feel like that Cisco moment at the end
said it all you know flash science bros
fist bump high-fives
I know I do high-fives at the end of all
my videos so it was kind of fun to see
ray Palmer try to high-five everyone
Oliver
clearly not a fan of high-fives really I
think that's just because Oliver is not
a fan of having fun we'll see if that
changes by the end of the season though
so onto my number one WTF moment Roy
leaves the team and Thea is killed by
Rachel Ghul so the Roy stuff first they
said that he's coming back before the
end of the season I think it's going to
be to help bring the back to sanity
because very clearly
Rachele Ghul is going to tell Oliver you
can throw her in the Lazarus Pit if you
join the league in the promo for the
next episode we see like a version of
that but he's the comic books when they
say you know going through the Lazarus
Pit going through that experience
changes your soul so I think Thea is
just gonna go like absolutely mad she
doesn't know that Roy is still alive so
she's gonna blame all of her go after
him
Roy will have to like come back to say
hey look I'm not dead see stop trying to
kill your brother and all your friends
and then she can go on to join team
arrow as the Mia Dearden speedy there's
gonna be a whole lot of other stuff
going on and then the final couple of
episodes but I think that's gonna be a
big part of the plot is like bringing
Thea back to sanity I feel like the
theory saga will fight like that brief
fight that they had went a long way
towards addressing villain decay you
should not be able to be racial in a
fight he is like the world's best
fighter doesn't that just make you
wonder how Oliver's gonna beat him in
the end there's no way he's gonna beat
him in a sword fight no matter how good
he gets racial goal is always gonna be
better if anyone takes down race I
actually kind of hope that it's Nyssa I
feel like that would be more appropriate
but here's my big question for you guys
you know what was your favorite moment
from the episode and do you think that
Roy is gonna come back like for his like
final cameo as part of this Thea plot to
like bring her back from the crazy
allows her to put experience if you
haven't read the comics or you haven't
seen Batman the Animated Series the the
episodes with racial goal in the Lazarus
Pit when people get resurrected they're
just crazy like they literally lose
their minds for a period of time usually
it's proportional to the time that
they've been dead so the longer
someone's been dead and that gets
brought back the longer they're gonna be
crazy but you guys asked for lazarus pit
resurrection and arrow is delivering so
it cannot be said that arrow does not
deliver on promises that it makes I mean
you can't just like show us a Lazarus
Pit and then that dump someone in it at
some point I know I didn't really
address the flashback scenes I think
what's happening here is that the Amanda
Waller character is slowly gonna be
cycled out because of the Suicide Squad
movie they're kind of doing that with a
lot of characters and it's a bit of a
bummer but it's one of the realities of
the way DC treats its TV and movie
characters so next week's episode takes
us back to the League of Assassins in
Nanda Parbat be sure to subscribe to get
that video it's gonna be all kinds of
WTF for the rest of the season also on
the flash - same deal tomorrow is
supposed to be the Batman vs. Superman
teaser so I'll do a video for that it's
also supposed to be a new Star Wars
Episode 7 trailer - so I'm gonna try and
do a Q&A for this video when those
videos are done I'm also working out
some new daredevil videos I know you
guys have been asking about that too so
hopefully I'll get all that stuff out by
Saturday it's been actually a really
good week of TV I've been really happy
so while you guys wait for all those
videos to post you can click here
for my agents of shield video from last
night if you haven't seen it yet and you
can click here for last night's episode
of the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow